if you already thought the Democratic
2020 candidates were a frightened pack
of cocktail weenies get a load of Beto a
guy so sturdy
he's as sturdy as a gummy worm you want
pathetic here's pathetic he felt he had
to apologize over a sick joke he made
about his wife
now before we play this joke you might
want to scoot the kids out of the room I
just got a call from my wife Amy who's
back in El Paso Texas where she is
raising sometimes with my help
Ulysses who's 12 years old Molly who's
10 and their little brother Henry who is
8 years old he apologized for that in
case you missed it he apologized for the
quote sometimes with my help
end quote he apologized for that ok
here's a quick mental exercise imagine a
guy apologizing for that ever becoming
president now he felt she had to
apologize because quote people were
outraged meaning three cranks on Twitter
but in the era of scalp first think
later humors the first to go when
cnn.com article claims many female
Democratic operatives we're activists
were triggered for once media can we get
a head count on many seriously what kind
of person gets offended over that when
the right response be look it's a joke
if you can't take a joke we're gonna
have a real problem when I become
president
sadly Beto went the other way
the way that I talk about our marriage
and also the way in which I acknowledge
the truth of the criticism that I have
enjoyed white privilege
welcome to the modern liberal man a
Snuggie full of guilt and fear notice
how he threw in that white privilege
just in case the virtue signal signal
are now brands our economy racist I
think the only way to meet some of these
historic challenges is to be able to use
this engine of capitals and won't be
government intervention or policy alone
that makes it possible now having said
that it is clearly an imperfect unfair
unjust and racist capitalist economy
okay now try other economies you know
the ones that aren't as awesome in
eradicating poverty our racist system
has done more to help humanity than any
ever but what would he know about
economies inherited and married his
money making him a perfect lefty relying
on the wealth of others to support his
silly ideas oversized ego and absurd
hand gestures but hey it sure beats a
real job all right one you you and I sit
here and we have made comments about
being married right we have made jokes
about what it's like to be married for
you a long time not so long he
apologized for that I thought it was
weak unnecessarily but I just I I'm a
big booster of fathers and so I do think
if it's if the idea is that you gotta be
involved you can't just be on the road
and say I'm making money I'm bringing in
the bread so baby you take care of the
kids that's I think that's out of line
but I'm a big booster of fatherhood but
he I think right now what you're seeing
on the left is a reaction which is that
they feel that they've got to somehow
conform especially in a time when as you
know slight slip-up can make big news
and knock you out of the race but I you
know to my mind if this is about Trump
going after his hand gestures people
saying he's PC and a snowflake
hey Republicans wake up this guy just
raised six hundred million dollars six
hundred
six million I was thinking in terms of
how he beat Dana Bernie Sanders he's way
ahead of Amy Klobuchar who's also raised
substantial amounts of money and even
farther ahead of Elizabeth Warren so to
me this raising this money was a
surprise great because I didn't know
that he was I knew he had raised 80
million in the Texas race against Cruz
and I think you wrote that off to Cruz
being a less than great candidate yes
but this now is against fellow Democrats
and people say we don't know him we
don't know his positions guess what
Democrats like this guy he has real
energy and using some of the Obama
people now flocked to his campaign I
don't know Dana you know the women were
upset because they couldn't make that
joke do you actually believe people are
sincerely outraged I was thinking about
though but I've made the joke in Reverse
it's not a child right but like I post
all these great pictures of Jasper on
Instagram I wrote a book about Jeff it's
debatable that they're great takes care
of Jasper yeah Peter not apologize
you're the yolk with the yolk oh he's
the John exactly he works from home they
think about the other part of this is
that there was a lot of people saying oh
we had such a bad roll out because baito
had to apologize and things well one
there's the money but also arguably
kirsten gillibrand had a much worse
rollout she officially announced this
weekend with the video and literally no
one's talking about it his roll out is
better because here we are we're leading
our show with it Jesse you know what I
think he's stealing your I am waters
this is my world thing that's doing it
in every scene that's a guy that likes
hand gestures I have to marvel at some
of these here's a new one that I didn't
know existed this is okay and then
there's the other one where he's talking
about his wife Amy he goes Amy Amy I'm
not sure what that represents but I also
don't understand why he apologized he
was actually praising Amy yes and what
is he supposed to do he's running for
president he needs to get out outside of
his house to run for president
take the kids out of El Paso and put
them in school in Iowa so we can
co-parent in Iowa I don't understand
he's like Gumby that's how soft this guy
is
I don't also like the white privilige
comment I as a white man understand I
probably have privileges that I don't
even realize I have but to say that race
is determinative of success I think is
unfair to all the other things like grit
determination good looks things like
that point and look at a successful
white person and say hey he got that
because he's white discounsel the hard
work that got there he has a different
kind of privilege he has rich parents
and rich white privilege which it's
pretty good privilege Emily what do you
make of this yeah I agree with you that
I think you know where beware if he
actually assumes that office for someone
who can apologize and Bend with a win
like that for something so little I
think the the media though is covering
for him he's running on charisma and
personal narrative I see none of it you
think I think it's before I think it's
it's ridiculous and I think you know the
whole like sitting on this story for two
years or whatever that group that he was
a part of that was a precursor to
anonymous and he said oh I was really
just on the margins and his quote was
like I wanted to be the cool kid I
wanted to be as smart as them and
whatever and that's what I see that he's
doing here there's no substance but for
some reason it's really spitballing and
it's snowballing and yet you know Bernie
Sanders just raised just a little bit
behind him so I don't think we should
count him out on the left and also he
shattered records with the Senate race -
like you said the fundraising and he
still didn't win oh there are two things
one that apparently there was a reporter
that hid an article about bay door work
until after the Senate race and it was
the excuse was he was writing a book
which is kind of interesting and then we
have Joe Biden accidentally announcing
he's running for president only
accidentally tolling it's criticized by
the new left eye the most progressive
record of anybody running for the United
run
you mean
did anybody who would run why is he
waiting can soft-launched
it's pretty soft I have to defend Joe I
think what he was saying is the United
States Senate because he's been running
for the Senate for at what three decades
look he's running it's just about it's a
foregone conclusion I think he has the
luxury of taking his time so I don't
worry about that with Joe I think the
bigger issue for him is and this comes
back to something we touching on with
baito about white privilege and all the
like is he going to be viewed as an
older white male or can he catch up I
think most Democrats especially in Iowa
just want someone who can beat Donald
Trump but to your point about Beto's
comment about racial and privilege white
males Jesse
when you go back and look at American
history look at look at real estate in
this country segregated neighborhoods
how wealth is built look at the New Deal
and who got excluded from the New Deal
typically agriculture workers people who
inject the black people I would agree
with that one but I would also say
there's a lot of very poor white
working-class people in this country
that look around and say what privilege
yeah great right but you there's no
question about the historical
disadvantage of being black that
compounds that whatever disadvantage
there was for poor whites then you got
to figure out what the solution is and
I'm skeptical of what the solutions are
that are being offered from that side I
have a few answers myself I'll share
them with you during the break